good morning millenials morning everyone
it is so early
okay honestly I don't know what's going
on because I feel sprightly as [ __ ] it's
because you got a planner and I mean I
this change could have happened so long
I couldn't agree more because I was too
I would spend it like 12:30 and I woke
up a little bit earlier because we did
an extra special timing table I'll tell
you why in a second but the planner like
put me at ease it was like a xanax do
you have anything to say to me you were
right except like this is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] at a glance that I got a
planner and it doesn't start till July
like what about James that's really
crazy though because it used to always
be they start like I hope I'm there in
January but now like if you buy them
online in July they give it to Sara
which is kind of cool but it's
unfortunate for your next two but didn't
want to ask like what I get is I guess
maybe they ran out of June's I don't
know okay well I can't give you a
planner a while ago that you should you
could use I've looked in the desk and I
couldn't find it and there's like a very
strong chance after it out that's so
rude I know I'm doing I was just trying
to help you feel so amazing and that
ease and sprightly so I'm looking at the
feed and I literally look like a part of
the chair look because I went oh wait I
have to pull look I'm I don't know where
the chair starts and I end that's nice
is it like a good look or is it working
or now it's very Josie on the first day
of high school
oh wow but no but it is before Labor Day
and after Memorial Day so you are um
you're going to find it's not feeling
super super great about myself what
whatever it I just don't like it we need
if you if you're wondering why my outfit
is so kind of mature and Real Housewives
desk it's because Jackie and I have been
trying to get an appointment at dr.
Sherin goosies office who was Ramona
singers plastic surgeon and I've been
saying on the show like we need to go to
Ramona singers past she looks the best
of any housewife who does her I knew her
name was Sharon G because I remember
hearing that the real hustlers of New
York franchise they came to her
Sharon Jeezy because they thought she
was like fabulous and had like cool
friends and she didn't want to be on the
show but she recommended a bunch of
ladies like Ramona so I knew it was
Sharon G and I went a little bit of an
Internet stalk session and I called
yesterday and she said that she just got
a cancellation for today at 11 o'clock
so obviously I wasn't gonna give up the
opportunity and you guys wouldn't want
us to give up and it's merely a
consultation I don't know what's gonna
happen I know it's gonna I want to hear
about her latest thing
happen technologies I'm really excited
so that's why we have to be out of here
at 11 o'clock but it's well worth it and
we knew you guys would understand if
anyone would understand it so servicers
and I know and will and will tell you
everything the hackers the appointment
and I just I'm personally going for this
sign of steamy Botox line and then like
a consultation about coolspot
liposuction and maybe like breaking my
knees and make me taller I don't know
okay
knee surgery I just want to hear what
the latest and greatest technology is
for like double chins that's what I'm
here it's kybella but maybe she doesn't
recommend it you know I want to hear
from a true professional people
something too [ __ ] people on
Instagram also like whatever like face
laser think that Ramona's got before
Mexico like wasn't right before Mexico
but like did wonders for her face it
would need to be a time where you have
truly nothing going on for the next
monkey like this weekend yeah then we're
staying home with her groceries oh my
god I'm so excited to stay home this
weekend the bend was out all night
literally he got home before in the
morning and like I've never been less
jealous even though he had the best time
and usually I have FOMO I'm like I
couldn't be less interested in that I
have great in that lifestyle yeah Mike I
got a peep out of order I'm out you know
yeah but before we go ahead up dr.
Sherin Kesey maybe it's Jeezy I don't
know here's E like gez probably Shang
he's eight here are the best five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast it's a little extra early
for you to eat your toast this morning
you know I'm not feeling good I was like
what is she saying you guys like I was
drunk yesterday last night going to bed
like I literally have never felt worse I
thought I was gonna die of heartburn and
then I took like heartburn medication I
leave everything drink water I thought I
would wake up feeling like a new person
the heartburn went away but the pain is
still here so I'm gonna power through
heartburn is a very real disease it's
very real disease and have some fun with
you I literally felt like my chest was
inflamed but I mean luckily ish Zach
deals with heartburn a lot so he has all
the tools do you ever get heartburn so
bad you feel it in your mouth that's not
what was happening big yes I understand
mostly happens like when I'm eating and
I get Harper like I get it sometimes
after I drank like tequila in my sleep
and that's the worst that's horrible
I'm sorry but sometimes I just feel like
it's a flame in my chest if I drink
water like it'll put it out but it
doesn't her hat yeah it doesn't also I
feel like I've heard that Botox actually
helps with headaches
and I do have a headache today so I look
forward to my botox and the only thing
I'm nervous is a you know I have an
extremely extremely low tolerance for
pain
they probably the lowest in the world
well that's actually impossible because
scientifically redheads have the lowest
tolerance for pain so while you're out
here complaining about your pain like
I'm actually suffered here's something
I'm not completely like I genuinely like
if I get pinched I feel it for like two
weeks
no but sane like something when
something was strapped on my foot
yesterday you had no sympathy for me I
was that's not true I've reenacted the
foot dropping and I said you know what
that actually does hurt and I
sympathized thank you sister
no anytime I walk into a corner like I'm
for a month I have to go to the hospital
same ok yeah well let you know how
painful it is or is it they use a
numbing cream we should be okay people
do this all the time it's a routine
procedure you've got a big bruise in the
middle of my forehead whatever I'm doing
it you can get Botox in your armpits to
stop sweating any that but I don't leave
a sweating problem mine I have a lot of
other projects on deodorant [ __ ]
I'm sure showering jeezy has for you
hold on okay first story is a developing
case of Pete and it's probably like a
dealer until it clears up your acne tell
your back me you know chest me your
armpit me yeah whatever okay in the
developing case of Ariana Grande and
Pete Davidson
Pete Davidson has covered up his tattoo
of Cassie David we have a photo of the
quote masterpiece that he that he used
so what did he get so he had her face
okay you guys are seeing on the screen
Claudia's seeing it on my iPad uh-huh he
had her face on his arm with a moon
above her and he just turned it all into
a forest she's still there though I see
her chin but I wondered like I wonder if
this made him things like maybe I
shouldn't get Ariana's name catchy maybe
the days of tattooing my girlfriend's
name are over but she is now his fiancee
well I want to say I got his D I'm
yesterday that like I said not like I
said like I'm going to say DMS aren't a
reputable news source
but someone did tell me in my DMS and
that they're somewhat connected to like
Pete Davidson's mom that he actually
bought that ring for Cassie I got the
same DM
and held on to it which would make sense
cuz they were together for so long but I
don't believe like just random DMS but I
just want to put that thought in
people's heads it's possible I don't
think
as he would wear that ring no she's very
demure she's very low-key and that ring
is very high key yeah so honestly though
like as much as I'm happy for Pete
Davidson and Ariana Grande look I really
think him Inc has a David we're like the
perfect couple in so many ways well
first of all in so many ways and one
just logistically like her name wouldn't
have to change it would do Cassie David
Cassidy Tipton yeah which is just really
nice for all of her monograms and her
toe boys and I would be happy for her
for him it's like he loves his girl and
she's the daughter of a comedic legend
where he could really hone his craft he
I'm sure he honed his craft so much
during the relationship also like she is
coming to write so they were just coming
off of each other but not in like an
annoying way it was getting to be too
much coming maybe need when does the
comic stop and real life start
and who's the funnier coming like I mean
with Ariana there's no question like
he's the comic she's the tower yeah and
like they each do their own thing and
they can each support each other but
when they're both like like fighting for
komak Hulu shows I don't know maybe it
was too much like it's like Carrie and
burger and he just couldn't but also
because he was like a terrible writer oh
yeah and the scrunchie even though she
was wrong because I am a woman
born in New York live in New York New
York woman and I wear a scrunchie all
the time same but she made a good point
like you would never wear a scrunchie
out on the town like you wouldn't even
wear it on your wrist and put it in your
bag and then if you're at a club you'd
put it in your hand finally got a mature
enough to like be aware of when there's
a position on my wrist I think it's the
ugliest thing and I don't I won't go out
with the ponytail my resume and whereas
like in college if you look at pictures
like ponytails up the wazoo oh but now
I'm too classy for that same that's just
an easy way to class up your walking if
anyone's looking to class it up
I feel like Pete Davidson covering his a
Cassie David tattoo is like an episode
of like ink wars you know like one of
those shows like NY ink
yeah with um Pink's husband is oh my god
is that him he's ink man yeah he's
tattooing oh my god yeah no he's a
tattoo artist Oh from Michelle from a
show okay yeah yeah so she really matter
daddy Chrissy of course Jake is using
James Jesse James Decker
no Jesse James no Decker Jesse James
from The Apprentice sure sure
what else Oh
you're done with these two honestly we
just said this we literally talked about
the same five people every day on the
show and it's like you get the news be
more interesting as we I was pulling up
these stories like it's these are the
people and it's not it's not the
Kardashians house it's really not it's
Mariana twisted and Chloe
Tracy McCauley mag and Marco yeah and
that's pretty much it for for today at
least okay next up Kim and Khloe
Kardashian on Maxim's Hot 100 as our
Kylie and Kendall Jenner but where's
Courtney oh my god Shaddai better in WoW
I don't know and if there's any hair for
Courtney to be on it would be this year
shortly before I had a five is pretty
damn good tell me what numbers they are
Oh Kim and Khloe along with younger
sisters Kendall and Kylie Jenner were
recognized but notice Lee left out was
the eldest sister Kourtney Kardashian
that is so awkward
the KGW beauty mogul 37 was selected in
the power players category for her
influence on social media and the beauty
industry as well as her impact through
television and magazine covers she did
win the inaugural influencer war not
this year's CFDA Awards Kardashian
West's fellow honorees in the section
are Megan Marco among Amal Clooney a
banker Trump and First Lady Melania
Trump honestly what a powerful bunch we
defer good for Kim for like smuggling
her ass into a category with Amal
Clooney you know what I mean like and
Megan would've thunk no and Amal and
Megan are friends and Kim needs to join
the French yeah 100%
okay meanwhile Chloe Kendall and Kylie
were included in the bombshells category
which highlighted supermodels and insta
stars and that's it okay I'm gonna say
something like my least the hottest one
who's that happen number one hot 100
evidences on could saw that article
because last year was Haley Baldwin
oh yeah how much over our Instagram
because I wasn't sold on it but this
year I would have been sold on it I mean
she's literally gorgeous but if you
could have it your own way who would be
number one
I mean like Kate Upton every single year
Oh totally like just I just could watch
her like she's just so beautiful and
interesting looking and she always like
looks different I don't know if she's
like gains weight losses like she looks
different every time it's just I'm so
obsessed with her yeah body I I think I
would go with stuff this is tough
who would I
choose I don't know I'm not in love with
anyone here you choose
know yourself of course but like you
know I don't wanna be obnoxious right I
mean I do deserve it but whatever I'm
trying to eat okay okay okay okay I kind
of liked when we used to rank that I
know it's like probably like so
misogynistic also I just find it so
interesting that like of all years for
Courtney to be left out this year like
yeah like this was her year like she got
in shape she literally weighs 90 pounds
is weird I know right I feel like it's
an ageist thing no totally and like I'm
not trying to be a [ __ ] but if any of
year like for Chloe to be left out it
wouldn't Chloe really doesn't make sense
this year because like she was pregnant
not that pregnant women aren't hot you
know what I mean but like just like this
is a physical thing yeah
Kate Upton was number ones Hot 100 so I
don't know if you guys munis and I guess
it's time to tell you but I'm the
editor-in-chief of and it's been a real
honor working on this yeah I'm happy for
you Congrats Wow
clammy I'm not okay what's wrong with
you I told you I was poisoned no one
believes me I was poisoned and this
isn't the first time I was I felt this
way after eating at mr. Chow just saying
oh my god you know I got um food
poisoning from Filipe once oh we all
yeah cuz it's like if you've gone to
believe it I mean they make different in
a dumpster and then service you it's
delicious but it will kill you it's
delicious V raccoon no this is the
second time like in the past few months
wear a tie mr. Chow and I came home just
feeling like unexplainably lethargic
like couldn't move
well because it's like really like
Reggie but don't eat anything crazy I
had fish string beans and lettuce wraps
vegetarian all vegetarian like all their
sauces are like legit like made with
sugar I don't use their sauces I don't
know I just didn't feel like it like I
felt like a million bucks is such a good
meal it was such a good meal I think
just feel like I don't deserve this pain
but you know it's Friday at least he did
eat it so I could do dessert about no
but I was measured in my eating whatever
it's really measured yeah I was measured
I wasn't like even eating like a crazy
person
then break break
you're gonna take your shine and even
sin take it take this love if you ever
loved me have mercy
I love that song it's so good and I want
to cry we should go to a bright young
concert I mean we did and it was
unbelievable in the last 2 20 minutes oh
that wasn't long ago she'd go to a
bright young like a headlining I
completely agree he's on tour with like
Sam hunt we gotta go and I think we
missed it also conformation I will not
be here for the Rascal Flatts concert
because I now that I have all my social
events in one place I realize like this
entire summer like I'm not gonna be able
to have one morsel of fun and you know
what it's sign I'm a working woman but
like last summer I was so free like I
was like I literally did not work for
one minute yeah I was out that didn't
you the dry six concert at Jones Beach
yeah you're gonna be the Hamptons um
okay so I'm sorry it's very sad it's so
sad gospel - Danny shy like I'm
literally Debbie sherry and I'm just
gonna die
Shannon Shea came out with a song with
Kelli Fox Mario has not something like I
I know the government is spying on me
but also apparently the Country Music
Association is and I'm just glad that
they're using all their information for
good because this is my dream
collaboration and then to not let me
down completely yeah okay are you ready
for your next story huh yeah are you I
don't think you're ready okay sing a
little more yeah you know what I write
you what should we watch I perform like
perform something easy on the ears like
lovely I just need to be like like a
lullaby
okay maybe look I got it you got okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
when you talk about oceans 8 oh my god
story that's the third story for now and
you know what here's the thing it was
definitely good like I didn't go to the
movies like you get yourself settled for
like a bad movie and you're like on your
phone the whole time I wasn't on my
phone I was intrigued I liked all the
actresses like being seeing all these
people in one place was it like an
amazing movie no was it better than the
other oceans movies I haven't seen them
but probably not any oceans movies which
is so crazy
I'd like okay so in general it was a
fine movie I the reviews I heard we're
like a little too rave for what it agree
but I would recommend people to see it
because sometimes you just want to see a
movie and it was a good animal to sign
film and I really liked the Met Gala
premise and the glamour and like that
really where there was a crime movie
like there was something for everyone
yeah it was almost like they tried too
hard to fit too many famous people in
the span of two hours like agree between
the eight really famous main characters
literally like Olivia Munn Kim
Kardashian Kylie Serena Williams
literally everything everyone was in it
and it was like really really trying so
hard like if you're gonna try that hard
this movie has to be [ __ ] spectacular
like I really wanted it to be glitz and
glam but it felt like overkill like I
wouldn't be I could have used 30% less
famous people but it's interesting when
you put that much like fundamental
sources into a film that much star power
it's either incredible or it's a total
bomb for it to be mediocre is almost
even more difficult and it was meteor
but still enjoyable and I don't want to
spoil the pop at obviously like it's a
crime movie and I don't know it's just
like I didn't feel like they were
justified in their pride in their crime
like I wasn't like I felt like the
jewels were better suited in the Costume
Institute then you know them and what
they did with their money like I didn't
even care no and also a lot of what they
do with their money like they didn't
need money for like a punch at riding on
a motorcycle like [ __ ] you were doing
that before no totally and like for the
amount of money that they stole like it
just seemed to be a little too greedy
for me
I agree I don't know and I feel like in
other movies other crime movies I don't
watch a lot of crime movies but one of
my favorite crime movies is the Italian
Job and they're stealing from someone
who stole from them like yeah get your
money justice I wasn't like a rooting
for them to steal like it just felt like
no you should go to jail like you're a
criminal yeah it was it was morally
ambiguous but you know who I really
liked in it James Corden I thought he
was very funny and I just really liked
him I did her an actually when it came
out that he was gonna be in it like
Twitter went insane they're like enough
James Corden like I couldn't agree less
I couldn't agree less also Rihanna was
fantastic her acting debut and there was
enough of her and we were worried on the
show that she didn't get just pushed to
the side but she there was enough of her
but not too much of her I believed the
character she wanted to be like is like
you know like earthy like uh tech badass
hacker yeah and like when she finally
like does get glam to go in the red
dress in the red dress it's like oh
Briana is the Met Gala oh yeah the girl
who's wearing the die like the Daphne
Kluger like that would be Rihanna if I
could have recast anyone it would have
been an Hathaway I'm sure incredibly
annoying I thought she did a really good
job dependent like she bothers like
actually you know she even bother me
that much anymore I'm seeing but that
did their day I just don't think it was
the right role for this person was
suppose to be that quintessential
Hollywood girl and like when you think
and halfway she's like she doesn't give
me that it honestly it should've been
like Kate Hudson no yes
she's so Hollywood like she would host
the Met Gala and it should have been
someone oh it should have been someone
playing themselves do you don't I mean
yes that would have been fine but Kate
Hudson would not be hosting the Met Gala
oh my god I'm she's open she's been
there a bunch of times no it should have
been Taylor Swift okay like someone
playing themselves like they didn't need
to make up a fake celebrity they had
every celebrity in the movie playing
themselves yeah but like then just
arbitrarily they choose who's the
biggest celebrity like that's kind of
weird too because it should've been
Rihanna and it would have been weird if
like everyone in the movie is a big
celebrity playing other people and then
there's one person playing themselves
and as someone who surprised me was
Aquafina
because it's obviously like this week is
her week like she's having a moment
she's in crazy-rich Asia and she's in
she is increasing yeah just that looks
so I know she's in oceans eight like the
universe has decided that she's coming
up from the internet and they've chosen
her and I wasn't on board with the
decision because like I always
like when the powers-that-be choose
internet people to like pluck from
obscurity until like mainstream media
they always pick the wrong people Allah
grace Helbig and then she ruins it for
all of us because they're like well you
know internet people don't work look at
grace Helbig show is terrible and nobody
watched it well maybe if you chose
someone better than grace Helbig people
would have bought [ __ ] argument over but
so I was like great they've picked
Aquafina she stinks she was really good
she looks really good in crazy rich
Asians and I was wrong about Aquafina
that's really nice of you to say thank
you I thought she was really good as
well yeah I had one more thing to say
but I didn't like overact like she knew
her place in the movie like she knew she
was like low on the totem pole and she
did her job oh I remembered what I need
to say Benari to need to sneeze and I
can't do it no it's not like yours look
at the light that will make me sneeze or
yes please makes you sing I don't want
to sneeze why because it's just a mess
you always want to see and it was just a
mess right now I don't have a tissue
what I was gonna say is the previews for
the movies that played before oceans 8
we're really good and I remember was
this time last year where I first saw
the preview for greatest showmen and
that kind of got me through the rest of
the year and I think that movie this
year is the Nutcracker it looked
phenomenal
it was more like beauty in the beasts
and greatest showmen but still okay a
work of art I went to the movie I mean I
went to the bathroom four times during
the movie it's weird that is weird look
I missed half the movie look I feel like
I can go literally a whole day without
pain but if I'm in a movie I just pay I
don't know I just hold it in and every
individual theater should have a stall
well especially like I pick cuz it's
like calmer when it's far and I pick
yeah I just think every sabatham should
have I mean every movie should have a
stall every seat should have just like
you got a lot of cover okay this next
story one of our favorite people to talk
about two of our favorite people to talk
about queen elizabeth gifts Megan Marco
dazzling earrings all about the duck
just his look okay so Megan and Queenie
had a now together out together and it
was a big honor because the Queen
invited Megan alone right and they took
the train and then they had to go
overnight on the train like the Queen
really she can fly yeah I don't know
Megan looked her best yet the dress that
she was wearing the I think it was it
was off the shoulder was Yvonne Shay
might have been it wasn't off the
shoulder it was a high-neck but then it
was like caped down it was perfection
like she should get that dress in every
color and wears everything more like me
highlighter green the queen is a raver
yeah like she would actually be teaching
concert after this so that's a dead
concert she went to Vegas and she went
to EDC yeah she had like I literally
love the Queen so much and I wonder how
I feel about her in the Megan Marko era
if I didn't watch the crown I just I
wouldn't have the respect for her that I
do which is why everyone should watch
the crown so there's a video of the
Queen and and not Anne Hathaway and
Megan Markel getting off the train and
obviously the Queen goes first and Megan
has to kind of wait in the winds because
like that's just so for a proper
protocol and the Queen is like moving so
damn slow and like Megan's trying to
move just as slow as her and it's like
really sad to watch because she's like
going down the steps which like it's one
step it could take our legit 0.4 seconds
the Queen is moving slow as [ __ ] and
Megan's like awkwardly behind her it's
an interesting watch it is that she
handles herself so well with style and
grace
on the say she's booty and she's grace
she's miss heroines are it's so exciting
and she's really been stepping up her
game ever since the wedding it's like
she heard our cries and for that I am
grateful like every event that she's
been going to every public outing it's
better and better I'm better huh
accepted she was seen that twice um no
did she it looks like she did maybe they
were just really similar when did they
decide to wear hats and when do they not
like when she got off the trench was
wearing a hat and also I'm very Pro re
wearing clothes like that's the most
really knows the only person who really
does that Kate yeah but and it's like
she wears [ __ ] like six times
why shouldn't you especially we all have
that one like church dress that you wear
every year every Sunday Royals just like
us
I couldn't agree more okay great anyways
I'm really happy for these two new
besties yeah okay this next story I just
put in because like I just would use any
excuse to talk about Lala
okay and robia but John Travolta's Gotti
is finally opening after nearly a decade
and it's not really John Travolta's
Gotti it's a dilemma Scotty and the
premiere was last night and yes it is
the movie that Kevin Spacey's in no
that's billionaire boys okay because I
was so confused because like everyone's
promoting and I'm like you guys should
like really be quiet but it's different
movie it's a different okay good now
there's no shadow cast on this film and
I will be seeing this movie like just to
support lalala of course and la la' is
actually in a new movie I saw called the
row
I think okay it's like a sorority it's a
sorority horror movie which is ever
gonna watch a horror movie it's gonna be
a fad genre with Lala Kent in it and I
think we should like do a screening
because sure I want to watch it on the
big screen actually I do have a really
big TV if you want to come and learn
okay the same size TV goodnight but how
many inches 70 okay how BIG's yours okay
John Gotti junior thinks the story of
his father's life should at least be
playing on a few more screens on the
Gambino's family's home turf the son of
the notorious mobster is to stress that
Gaudi is only playing a few theaters in
Brooklyn
oh is this is like a sink piece okay it
got bad reviews
so here eyes big I don't care
Ron Tomatoes is wrong Rotten Tomatoes is
rotten okay here's the thing
the lobster ever heard of it no of
course not
it's a terrible indie movie with Colin
Farrell I think we're oh and Rachel wise
we're okay I'm gonna be able to tell you
about it but I was going to the movies
one night I like a regular and I wanted
to see something good I didn't need to
see the most amazing move ever just let
see like a fine movie see this movie
playing never heard of it 98 I run
Tomatoes oh sure why not
night and life ruined okay literally the
worst movie I've ever seen it I don't
trust Rotten Tomatoes anymore like you
know you know what's a number one most
rated movie on Rotten Tomatoes like out
of like the top ten the lobster boyhood
look I mean really that's what you're
putting all your eggs in way hood is my
lobster it's just like and who are like
who are the critics like are they oh yes
they're obviously like old straight
white men who don't know they're not in
tune what's necessary they should really
hire some toasters no but then also
critics are like the people because then
also like get out had a hundred percent
on Rotten Tomatoes like that was worthy
no no but they have bigger than my way
yeah
critic and audience I trust the audience
way more in the audience when is know
she is like because he's [ __ ]
stuck-up critics what the hell do they
know
and like greatest showman critics did
not enjoy it but the audience did it's
still number one on iTunes
that's so crazy nobody it's no greatest
showman is still number one on iTunes
since its release in the summer like why
isn't we talking about this success no I
know and Margaret told me that I'm like
that's not true and then I went to a
looking like it's a hundred limits today
every day yeah hold on let me look today
and it's so worthy like where's iTunes
I'm right I don't even use iTunes okay
running out
because it's a slow day and you know
it'll be back up there don't worry I'm
not worried about it I got it on vinyl
that's let's just so I can see my
children when there was like you know
like when we were in high school like he
were trying be like Indy they would like
bye-bye and I was like a bunch of my
friends do that like hung them on their
wall I'm like who are you guys fooling
you don't even have a record player
that's not what I'm trying to do it's
just sometimes it's nice if you're gonna
use it as like decor that's lame no
that's not they're actually all of our
vinyls are in a box but um now we have a
Bluetooth speaker sound system in the
apartment so when we wanna play loud
music we just do it through that whereas
before we would hook the vinyl up to a
speaker and then that's how we have that
me like that was our speaker but to me
that's just trying so hard to listen to
a song like just put on the Alexa no but
like then you just listen to an album
sometimes Alexa hang on goes roving on
sometime so I think I was four oh I know
what you're gonna do don't do it don't
do it no no I'm not gonna do anything
about I know you're gonna delicious wait
Alexa play rainbow by Kacey Musgraves
it's a great song now bunch of people
are gonna just start enjoying what song
was that our fits story no our this
story is that so Gisele Bundchen shamed
Instagram models the other day and now
she's saying that her model comments
were misunderstood okay Gisele Bundchen
is backtracking on her thoughts about
Instagram models and how judges operate
a boat over in Herveaux cover story
published on Thursday the 37 year old
supermodel said she'd never turned to
social media to promote herself like
models such as Gigi Hadid and Kendall
Jenner do in this day and age it's not
my generation I have to be honest about
that I'm older wiser
bündchen said if I had to promote myself
in the way girls modeling now have to do
forget it I wouldn't do it and then she
said I'm sorry that my words in my most
recent vogue article were misunderstood
my intention was simply to express that
I come from an older generation and I'm
not too technologically savvy alright if
she said anything bad I admired the
younger generation in their scale to
manage all that added demand of social
media
Jimenez really demanding apologies from
everyone these days she said nothing bad
all she said was that if she had to grow
up in the generation of like being a
Instagram thought like she never could
because it's just not who she is okay
that's a very fair statement she didn't
grow up in the Instagram age therefore
it she can understand it right I don't I
don't disagree with anything she said
nor as an Instagram model myself am i
offended by any of it literally over the
weekend someone asked me if I was an
Instagram model who asked you okay so I
told you I was in LA for pride and I
went to like this big
like gay extravaganza and if someone's
birthday was at a pool party everyone
was like ripped and I was like already
sitting in the corner with my shirt on
and like a jacket and like a puffer and
this guy came over and he was like
talking to me and we were just like
talking about like you know work
whatever news like what do you do and I
was like I have an Instagram he's like
oh you're not all and I was like now you
say I am coming oh yeah I forgot I
forgot okay so I was like I'm Instagram
and he was like oh you're are you a
model and I was like yes I am thank you
that's so flattering I know I think he
was just like you know being flattering
I don't think he actually thought it was
a model but one can dream but it's
really crazy how like everyone's a model
these days like if you look at people's
instagrams like it says model clearly
like mine but even just like regular
people it's like the things that you
post your interim now it's not like
friendly photos it's just like me
modeling where I am yeah most people's
instagrams are photos of them alone
modeling which back in the day was like
just use it or if you ask someone to
take a picture of you alone it was like
the most shameful thing ever like when
we were growing up yeah no but your
pictures or die it's really so crazy
like technically my Instagram I'm an
Instagram it's your portfolio no like
every picture that I take I am modeling
technically unless I'm smiling model
smile commercial I'm so commercial do
your mom I don't have a Mentos
commercial face I don't have an
editorial bone in my body I have so many
commercial basis I guess you could learn
something for me let me say yeah that's
good
it's basically open mouth smile like I'm
having a good time or even like now I'm
like playing with my kids you know yeah
but this like this is much I feel like
I'm much more editorial because like you
know I'm like you're hard yeah yeah and
I think you know it's always like an
interesting hand place and then it's
like yeah with like dramatic makeup or
you are like yeah just something that
conveys emotion that you know it's stoic
but but not unfriendly no I completely
agree something a little bit darker than
commercial exactly you just have that
darkness so it's rocky and I have to jet
off to dr. Sharon Jeezy we will update
you it's just a consultation so nothing
could happen but I have a feeling a lot
of is gonna happen I'm really I really
hope I don't chicken out like I'm kind
of nervous I have a very low tolerance
for pain I have already consulted with
myself about this Botox so no matter
what happens
unless she literally ran out of Botox I
am getting my steamy Botox I'm done this
is the last time you guys will see me
make this face please you know let me
say to the face you'd do it I hate this
face I don't wanna be able to do it
anymore and I'm just so excited for a
new things I hope you guys have an
amazing weekend if you have some
time and you want to get tickets to the
dirty jeans store which is my comedy
tour happening this summer head over to
girl [ __ ] calm or Claudia Sri calm
where you can find tickets to Denver to
Alabama to st. Louis I'm coming to DC DC
I know that was easy
filly our nightly shows capital I know
maybe I'll come with you there do you
think I haven't been since the seventh
grade do you think they want me to sing
the national anthem somewhere yeah yeah
all right for sure no you need to be
singing the national anthem in there
like some minor league baseball games
you know oh my god totally if you work
in the town where you have it like a
minor league baseball team or a major
league and you need someone to sing the
national anthem
hand me up or like I feel like hockey is
very like open with you today let's sing
the national anthem a lot of children up
and comers no I feel and like I'm not
bad I'm not am I asking a lot I don't
think when Mason Rams did it he [ __ ]
stunk like I could do a better job
he didn't stink you guys yeah and you
know he that after that he had to cancel
his next show because he lost his voice
at CMA fest that's why okay because he's
so bad okay you guys yeah have a great
weekend we will see you on Monday
hopefully looking a lot different oh my
god I'm so excited